hi everything will find I play Mike on
stranger things I'm really will be brown
and I play eleven I'm Noah schnap and I
play will buyers
hi I'm Natalia dire I play Nancy wheeler
hi I'm Charlie heat like by Jonathan
buyers
hi I'm Denker Montgomery hi I'm David
Harbor I play a chief hopper on stranger
things clearly I'm also too sweet I'm
Caleb and I'm Sadie I'm Cary Elwes and I
play mayor Klein
hey I'm Kara Bono I play Karen wheeler
on stranger things and we're about to
take this which stranger things
character are you quiz mm-hmm let's do
it
[Music]
shoes and 80s movie The Goonies Back to
the Future Busters and The Terminator
everybody all right I will choose the
Goonies the B team I'm going to choose
[Music]
eighty Oh which I do different so I get
a typical yes I mean yeah job do all do
that you can do garlic signal okay and
I'm gonna straight off to say Indiana
Jones rate is the Lost Ark I remember
going to the movie theater when that
came out and it was such a seminal film
for me I mean I feel like I'm already
headed down the hopper road with Indiana
Jones and whereas the Lost Ark that has
to be my choice I'd say back to the
future hey Laverne I love ya we will
yeah
the Terminator I love the term II I mean
obviously the Goonies feels really close
to Ghostbusters is fun too though
alright say I'm going Goonies both
calling Goonies
pick a superpower telekinesis flight
super strength super speed invisibility
and teleportation I'm thinking
invisibility because I've always wanted
to have invisibility because you can
really do any prank you've ever wanted I
would say it feels too teleportation yes
rotation and I want to get places fast
yeah me too I don't want to fly
teleportation I'd like to just be able
to you just be in the places I want to
be there it can be really convenient so
hateful and then you don't have to miss
people
oh I mean I got to choose this just with
my heart I know that probably if you're
going for hopper you're probably gonna
go super-strength right but I am gonna
go invisibility because it clearly is
the greatest superpower in the world
teleportation because think about how
much we travel and how easy would be
just to like oh that's and also like on
a weekend we like go to Paris again
I would have to say I'd like
teleportation I like the idea of being
able to teleport myself from one place
to another without any stress I think
that would be cool flight and I can get
away I think flight I feel like everyone
wants to fly right Super Stretch and New
York edges
yeah your friends would describe you as
loyal funny charismatic kind relaxed is
probably not one and logical I would
hope that my friends find
kind I'm not allowed to pick them all I
don't know I would like to think that
they would consider me loyal finally I
would describe you as loyal funny
charismatic kind relaxed I would just to
let you know I would describe you as
relaxed
yeah I'd say relaxed and I view as
charismatic a little spat that's
sometimes I would say I like to think
I'm funny I don't think I but if I did
that would make me look like a douche so
I'm making you put funny but funny awful
funny okay guys what should I put uh you
should put I'd say kind actually okay I
think okay now you do charismatic or
definitely yes pairs matter yeah what do
you think my friends would describe me
as an occupation charismatic I think
you're super loyal like a dog look
that's how you think okay yeah I know
your mind so like I'm they'd be kind and
they'd say I was charismatic I'm pretty
logical very practical I'm your go-to
person in an emergency like if the world
is falling apart and buildings falling
on your go-to person
what do you describe man it's logical
logical really yeah okay I'll take it
and for you relaxed well I was either
relaxed turmoil but I feel like I feel
like relaxed it's like a big-time
big-time choose a place to hang out with
your friends you've got community pool
palace arcade mics basement junkyard
Hawkins middle school or star court moon
Eric and Stockholm or better go for that
I wanna say the stock quote more I would
say the arcade okay not the junkyard
another catch and kill it could be cool
I'm gonna go to the basement actually
let me go with the mall I'm gonna hang
out at the palace arcade because I love
video games especially retro ones I'm a
master at Galaga a master star court
mall the mall because then you have
arcades in the mall I go I'm gonna go
with Palace arcade
junkyard for me yeah so that was like my
second rice
choose some 80 slang bitchin tubular
gnarly and wicked Charlie bitchin I'm
going for gnarly because people still
use gnarly rightly well we still use
gnarly a lot in our household so I guess
we'd have to go with that it's not
really good yeah gnarly I like gnarly a
hundred percent gnarly I love that
saying I still use that gnarly for me
I love wicked the musical I'm gonna go
with wicked wicked wicked I think it's
it's the test of time then a crisis
you'd be super calm calm
cautious nervous strategic responsible
or brave maybe that was not served as
diet yeah yeah laughs there was a giant
if there was poop in your pants and
crying on the floor who's communist my
honestly do you think that you would be
it how would you be cautious I think
it'd be nervous yet nervous I'd be
nervous too
I'd be responsible I highly doubt of the
you commando I'd be strategic I think
I'd probably try and be strategic and I
think I'd be brave or calm so strategies
probably Kings I would say strategic
strategic cautious I feel like I would
be brave to you would be brave I think
I'd be cautious had become what do you
think you think you'd become a crisis so
you think of a crisis though like yeah I
think I'd become and maybe
sure I think I'm try strategic or
strategic strategic okay is there one
that's like freaking out on the Forbes
hyperventilating I think I'm nervous
nervous efficiently and finally choose
something important from the series so
Christmas lights the alphabet wall Muse
Bob
Steve's bat Eggos or dart it's not
Steve's back well you're right my bad
hey guys I would use bat fun you know I
might say the bat one oh Christ is just
gonna hit you might want the back oh
yeah I'm gonna go
Steve's bat sorry music honestly the
most tragic death of the entire series
so look I like dot I would have to say
Eggos I was so fascinated by that whole
theme of eleven thing into waffles all
of them are important but I'm going to
go with the one I left behind barb are
you kidding me I got well I got eleven I
got Mike I could like I got Mike I'm 11
and I apparently max I got max I would
be Lukas
I got max I got loogie that's so weird
it could take you a while to warm up to
people and trust them but when you find
people you care about you'd stop at
nothing to protect them you have a
strong moral code and know how to find
joy in the little thing no no one ice
wish I got well in here I'm like your
smart optimistic open-minded you're a
leader not a follower and you make
decisions with your heart you're brave
trusting and would do anything for the
juices yes I got will you're smart kind
and somewhat shot you value honesty and
you always put others needs ahead of
your own you have a creative mind a big
heart and a youthful process pretty true
you're a cautious and level-headed
member of your friend group you think
carefully before you make decisions and
are always realistic you can be
defensive at times what you have a good
nature and love to have fun I feel like
that's pretty accurate yeah I think
that's so accurate you're spunky smart
and you don't care what others think of
you you aren't easily trusting but when
you find the right group of people to
open up to you're a loyal team player
they would do anything
friends the irony that I am my sister
clearly I'm oh go buy a red wig and a
skateboard
you